[Music]
you
who the [ __ ] do you think you're dealing
with uncle Joey here Wednesday morning
the 19th of October
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive you swingin dick you're giving
bubble gum you're healthy and you don't
give a [ __ ] because it's Wednesday
[ __ ] you're gonna go out there and
take what's yours and what ain't yours
that's the type of [ __ ] day it is
today I'm feeling a little better my
back to start the straighten up I don't
think I'm ready for jujitsu another day
I'd see the doctor tomorrow at 4:00 and
he said it will let me know what the
[ __ ] I need to do but besides that I got
a thousand things to do that all right I
gotta meet with people I'd rather jump
up and down we got a podcast in that
eight o'clock
getting ready for fever Las Vegas next
foot [ __ ] Thursday and Friday
Halloween weekend in Vegas at the South
Point don't go see the baby at karate
today you know I got [ __ ] they're doing
[ __ ] to see but I always got
time to smoke a jar of my favorite
[ __ ] people in the world will be
smoke and tell you a little
[ __ ] brain freeze
a little [ __ ] flow you
understand because you know me I'm
always on top of my game when I come to
flop when it comes to the reefer I'm
saying I'm a little [ __ ] slow I'm a
little [ __ ] I'm a little [ __ ] up
when it comes to reefer I'm on the
[ __ ] money you understand me
but joy enough with the chitty-chat
let's go mother flopping down right
let's get down
it's ones that'll don't let you out
they're monks the [ __ ] wolves you
know I'm saying because you are
[ __ ] wolf we're out there
looking for sheep today sheep victims
whatever the [ __ ] anybody missing I hope
you understand these [ __ ] guys
walking around yeah they give an
envelope up all the time just gotta look
them in the eye I said give me that
[ __ ] paper I'm worth the cops sucker
but that's it I'm feeling good I'm
looking good I'm healthy my family's
healthy and I got you [ __ ] I
can't lose and I got a big ball read for
you understand me once you got reefer
and you guys I can't [ __ ] lose I'll
tell you guys I love smoking reefer in
the morning
it makes me [ __ ] understand me I'm
feeling good had a nice meeting
yesterday I saw my boy Shane
Lisa Alison [ __ ] Beverly Hills doing
her a [ __ ] podcaster days coming up
yeah
shit's crackling up but the most
important thing is that you're happy
you're healthy and you're swinging a
dick all I wanna know is your swinging
dick dawg okay I don't wanna hear no
[ __ ] [ __ ] let me know how he's
going out there and choking
[ __ ] and get what belongs to
you take them lunchboxes and draw on
them [ __ ] away but listen Joey what's
it - chitter chatter spark that soaked
look at that [ __ ] tremendous and
that's it and that's that I ain't doing
[ __ ] this week taking a week off from
stand-up make them little notes getting
my head together spending some time with
the family at night just watching TV
normal like a normal [ __ ] suburbanite
you know I'm saying just watching TV
which slip is on the [ __ ] roll who's
better than me but next week I'll be
back
starts with Vegas then I got another
week off then I go to [ __ ] Boston the
Foxwoods casino and then we go to
Houston to some [ __ ] comedy fest over
Todd Barry and bunch of [ __ ]
are the savages
and that's it you got [ __ ] the
holidays that's it next week is
Halloween
once Halloween has done that [ __ ]
Tuesday it's all oh but to shout
strap on the seatbelt this time moose
[ __ ] fast jack one minute you dressed
up like some [ __ ] [ __ ]
an x-men yeah your [ __ ] parents house
eating [ __ ] Christmas dinner you're
broke you got no [ __ ] job you got no
future so you better move quick
[ __ ] I know what it's like not
bad with [ __ ] future at 35 so get on
it [ __ ]
there's still time you're not out of the
[ __ ] woods yet a lot of people and
listen I was [ __ ] 38 I had [ __ ]
three dollars in the bank I had 2,000
people looking for me but you know what
I didn't give a [ __ ]
I went underground and I kept doing what
I loved and nobody saw me and here we
are [ __ ] you know 20 years where what
the [ __ ] I was 15 years later
it's not all about the paper it's about
your health and how you make the [ __ ]
steps to get there you know that what's
the most important thing is the [ __ ]
journey and nobody had a [ __ ] better
journey a man slept in cause Greyhound
buses you know I felt coming all around
this country in a Greyhound bus on a
[ __ ] dime shoplifting cigarettes and
food at airports you to come proud of it
but no this is where I was and [ __ ] them
all they can't take that away from your
dog it's [ __ ] once they get out there
stab a [ __ ] and make the best of
what you got you may not know a lot but
you do have one [ __ ] thing can get
you to the other side that's all I had
one thing to get me to the other side no
matter how bad a [ __ ] shape I was you
know the other thing is hard [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
you don't save me hanging out I was
still there that would phones and I
don't give a [ __ ] it's a one-man
operation you understand me when your
mom and you came out of your mom's
snatch tubes in that biblical cord when
they cut that [ __ ] that's it you
don't belong to no gang you're in your
[ __ ] home I'm in my own game I'm not
here you know that guy he's got so much
money he's great he's got a bottle give
a [ __ ] about those [ __ ] but you
wanna get a holiday this Wednesday
[ __ ] light that [ __ ] up write
your goals drink the harmless Moody and
get out there with a [ __ ] knife you
do that six months in a row you'll get
some [ __ ] result you backg amigo
enjoy what the [ __ ] happened I did a
small he went out nice my shoes are
shined yeah I'm shoplift on make it
happen that's it
nice
and that's it and that's that I hope you
have a nice little situation with young
people Joey you know sometimes I'm a
little intense but the life the world is
intense I got time to [ __ ] giggle I
never had time and giggle always gotta
do something you always gotta do
something there's always there's an
envelope [ __ ] somewhere with your
name on it you understand me always
remember I'm up in the stratosphere
somewhere which I'll [ __ ] name you
gotta be the mailman and go out there
and get a [ __ ]
nobody's only get it for you [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
that's it and as that [ __ ] and I
go meet some people now and do my thing
and I come back and put the iPod I take
a little walk about in the neighbor 45
minutes but I'm gonna fat get that bad
[ __ ] them lungs and [ __ ] on I got
my bas Rutten mouthpiece I think I'll
walk around the [ __ ] Bay but I
wrecked hug suckas and that's it and
that's that
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight 8
o'clock don't come in [ __ ] crying
don't come in hit I want you have a
[ __ ] great day then come see me
alright and beside that it's your lucky
day [ __ ] uncle Joey gave you a
little blessing we talked about our
goals together we talked about how I'm
[ __ ] to make it happen
ain't nobody gonna be there for you
[ __ ] walk with alright you gotta make
it happen yourself and that's it I'm
gonna keep doing bong hits not you
[ __ ] later
I love it on my heart [ __ ] the people
see [ __ ] oh yeah I'm with desire
they're dealing come I'm at the lobbying
ahoy